There's a thing in a, uh, Sweden. I saw,
where is it? I thought I had it here.
Dude. This is funny, man. Seaside towns.
High-tech anti-sex toilets or spray users with water. Not going to stop them.
What if you have the one? That's your kink? Oh dude, you're going to get,
Hey, getting sprayed is part of sex.
Uh, no, but there's there's I don't know.
Loose in porthcawl. I mean,
loose in porthcawl South Wales all made up.
Where are you from? Loose. Oh, in porthcawl. Yes.
South Wales head made it all up where it will feature weight,
sensors and sound alarms to stop. Anti-social use dude.
This is so weird to me that this is where.
We're at.
This is on the guardian,
the Welsh seaside town of porthcawl is planning to install anti-sex public
toilets that would spray occupants with water and sounding an alarm. All right.
So look, first of all, how much is going on in these,
in the, in these toilets? Okay. Like, is it just,
is it just all day? Because then okay.
If it's not all day, then just who really cares, you know,
consensual sex in bathrooms.
Okay.
Violent movement sensors would automatically open the doors.
Oh, I can't.
I mean, dude, they want to see it.
Violent movement sensors would automatically open the doors and sound high pitch
alarms with fine water jets, soaking the interior.
The sexiest thing ever. So all of a sudden you're,
and then he's going to go and it's gonna go,
the doors are gonna open and then you're going to get doused with water and
you're going to be wet. ah, sexy yet.
The government has a King. I mean dude.
South.
Wales. What does that Welsh says sexy.
They're not going to stop him, dude.
I'm running to that thing. I want to.
And you're going to have people watch and spray me with water. K,
that dude. When the goes, boom, and the doors open and I get down with water.
I'm going, ah, I'm amping it up, dude.
I'm amping it up. My babies for real.
You think I won't that dude.
A hundred percent while the goes down
and I'm in there with a dude, the dude and just,
I don't give a dude. Oh, here it comes.
Are you kidding me? Oh no, here it comes.
The water. Oh, what? What's going on over there. I'm Whoa,
what's going on over there. Oh, here we go.
Blast all over whatever their names are
all over Christian.
That's the only guy I know. That's well she's Christian Bell.
Real dude. Are you kidding me bro? That's it?
Why can't I move the thing? Can't move it. Great. Yes. Can't move it.
Can't move the soundboard thing. Why is it happening?
Can't move the soundboard thing. It's up there and I can't move it. Technology.
Jude, send it over to want fire babies. Yeah, dude. That's ridiculous.
Why would you want to be, I mean, how much.
Is going on in, in, in Welsh land, in Westland?
How much is going on over there in bathrooms?
Here's the other thing do here's the other thing too?
Not here's the other thing too.
So spending so much money on this alarms,
doused with water, weight sensors, bro. You know how much a weight sensor is?
I swear to God, they're a hundred grand. I have that on full authority.
That weight sensors are a hundred grand.
Look at this poor called town. Council is spending, Oh, here we go.
170 Euro thousand dollars or whatever the it is.
That little E with the curvy thing at the top go, you know what I mean?
What is that? That's probably around the same.
I'm a member American in Griffin park.
According to Wells online, the planning documents detail,
a range of security features to deter rough sleeping.
You mean sleeping, dude.
Sit. They didn't want to admit it. Oh,
wa sit there and don't want to admit that they're pervy. Yes.
Hello. We are Welsh. We have planning documents to detail.
A range of security features to deter rough sleeping. I swear to God,
Including an audible warning,
combined with the lights and heating being switched off with lights and
heating being switched off. I want it to,
but I'm freezing.
All toilets would be fitted.
All toilets would be fitted with a full.
Sure floor and wall washer,
which could be operated after every use Jesus.
Christ. You know, so much.
This is how you know nothing's wrong and where as well.
Whales.
That's how you know nothing's wrong in Wells in America where like everyone's
dying and getting shot. And in Wales they're like, ah,
let's put weight sensors in our public restaurants because we don't want people
to be having too good of a time.
Uh.
I'm moving to Wales dude and in, where is this?
Porthcawl in Griffin park, dude. I'm going there, bro. that.
That's a red light. What if you went in there and it was all like,
like red lit and. And Leslie's like so nice.
They had paintings on the wall that were like, like, yo,
this is the kind of the they're trying to trap you, dude. They want you to,
but also want money out of it all.
Tell us we'll be fitted with a full high pressure floor and wall washer that
could be operated after every use or after a certain number of users per day.
Each night,
the toilets would close for 10 minutes while the unit undertakes a deep clean.
Wow, this is some weird Robocop.
Visitors will have to pay to use the toilets.
What, what.
Why would you have to pay to use? Take a. Hey, Oh man.
If I was going to a place and you had to pay to take a, guess what? I'm doing.
And outside of it right there, bro. I'll close to where you pay.
You think I won't. Close to where you pay. That's the real for real.
You're going to make me pay the. Where's the doorway dude. Here we go.
[Inaudible].
Oh, what's he doing bro? You're not charging me to take dumps.
Oh, that guy's crazy. What the? Oh,
I see outside the doorway because there were Oh,
because they wanted me to pay for it.
God he knows the rules. Doesn't he? God he lives a sound life. God.
He's got a code like Dexter. This is coming out anyway.
You're not gonna make me pay for it.
Um, however, Twitter users have questions. How the systems in particular,
the weight sensitive floors would work in practice.
One said just the fact that anyone would tweet about this one said weight
sensitive floors did detect more than one user.
What baseline weight are they using? I'm easily the weight of two teenagers.
And what about people who need assistance? I have to go in with my kids. Oh man.
Imagine you walk in with your two kids that need to take a.
And all of a sudden they douse you with water and alarm goes off and the doors
open and then they think you're a pedophile by the way. Oh,
you went in with kids. He's trying to kids. What the?
You're just an American in there. I was on vacation in Griffith Griffin park.
I don't know what's happening, dude. What the is happening?
Oh no.
Oh yeah. You need to take your. Oh, let's all go in together. Cause I don't.
I trust anybody.
We all got to get in to get in there and this is a family and every I,
here we go. I forget.
Oh no. What the is going on? Oh no. Wait, what the? Hi.
C'mon kids here with town now.
[Inaudible].
Another added.
There are obvious serious questions about weight sensors with potential for
cruel humiliation of facility users. As the robot.
Concerned with one thing, there are a,
be a serious questions about weight sensors.
They'll put in Chiala for a Cruella humiliation.
No facility users. I would like to take a.
I weigh an excess of three on Rhoda in 10 pounds.
Oh.
Oh my circuitry. Oh, water.
Okay.
Why would you listen to this podcast? Dude? There's NPR.
Talking about robots in whales and getting blasted.
The it's an escape from reality dude. That's like man,
[inaudible] um,
what's the one with the Ram Ram and he's the existing facilities are.
Close in October while the demolition and construction of new build of the new
building takes place due to amazing. So go take a and wham.